[Music]
[Applause]
our good friend Dave Lapham he's the
Bengals radio network analyst he's been
doing it for over three decades and uh
was there on the call yesterday last
night as the Bengals bow out in dramatic
fashion how would you sum up what you
saw last night Dave
well firsthand I want to compliment you
on your man cave it is the best I've
ever seen there's no question about this
thank you Dave but
what I what I saw was a team that uh
lost too many situational football
categories uh they were outperformed on
third down they're outperformed in the
Red Zone they lost a turnover battle by
one and you know these are things that
you just can't uh can't have happen and
then
interestingly enough I mean it was
ironic almost the thing that cost them
the football game ultimately was
something that they've done also well
all season long they're the second
fewest penalized team in the National
Football League all season long
in terms of yards second fewest penalty
yards in the entire league tied for
fourth in terms of number of penalties
assessed they have not self-destructed
by penalty well in the biggest game of
the year they're self-destructed by
penalty when Joseph lost track of where
he was on the football field and he's
very aware I mean he's a smart guy very
aware player it just happens and and he
pushes the homes and gets uh called for
the a critical penalty to put him in
field goal range it goes from a 60-yard
field goal to a 45-yard field goal to to
win the game at the gun and uh so it's
it's ironic that it all unfolded that
way but just about every situational
football category
that you have to at least Break Even
when some of them across the board
Kansas City Chiefs took all of them so
it was amazing to me Bengals were in the
game to the extent they were this is how
it sounded on the Bengals radio network
the call of Joseph a size penalty on
Patrick Mahomes
two receivers out to each side Mahomes
with a deep drop now moving in the
pocket running to the right and running
well he's at the 50. he's trying to run
for the first down he goes and the
Bengals push him after he was out of
bounds multiple flags are going to
attack 15 yards onto this play eight
seconds left in regulation and with that
penalty the Chiefs will be in field goal
range man you have to be more aware this
football team has got a lot of awareness
not on that play So that's Dave with the
color commentating and speaking for
Bengals Nation on that and you knew you
knew what had just happened there not
keeping your emotions inside that's for
sure
yeah that uh when when the penalty was
was was called and it should have been
the thing that I have is I agree with
some of your poll responders man the
officiating stocked very inconsistent
you know and Dan I've said all along I
why do you break up officiating Crews
and have the All-Star Cruise these guys
haven't worked with each other all year
long I mean it's you know it we know
that a team is not necessarily built up
of you know nine MVPs in baseball or 11
MVPs in football it's a team everybody
has a role everybody has a
responsibility everybody works together
and you work with the same guys all year
long and everyone gets to the most
important games of the year they messed
it up they muck it up I I don't get it
but at any rate you know that's a that's
another I guess another subject another
topic but
um I that should have been a penalty Joe
burrow gets smoked after he throws the
football gets hit up and by his shoulder
pads there's a backwards somersault gets
up looks at the official like what you
know I mean that was well after I threw
the football you know the the
inconsistency of it
um and Joe same thing Joe scrambled for
a first down out of bounds both feet in
the white in the five yard white area
gets pushed no call well you know that
was it was close
um but you could have called it and it
wasn't that close with homes that one
had to be called
yeah I just never felt like the chiefs
were out of control it just felt like
they were always doing something just a
little bit better than the Bengals the
Bengals were desperate trying to keep
something alive the fourth and sixth
that they went for uh you know to start
the fourth quarter it just felt like
they were always a step Beyond a half a
step behind with the Kansas City Chiefs
as they moved to next season Dave
what do you see with the Bengals any
changes any additions
yeah there always are you know uh last
year's football team that went to the
Super Bowl uh the makeup of this
football team was much different you
know the highly publicized uh signing of
three veteran offensive lineman and free
agency and then they go and draft one uh
who ends up being a starter all season
long in Boston so they they redid their
offensive line I mean there are
definitely going to be tweaks
um you know every phase had their
moments of uh of lack of execution
including special teams Chrisman
unfortunately had the worst punting day
of his of his season at the at the most
inopportune time and uh you know that
the punt return killed him and there was
an illegal block on it that wasn't
called I mean you you can go through
these games when you comb through them
you can find all kinds of things but
flagrant things on big plays you know
that's tough when they're not called
sometimes uh but at any rate you're
going to have to improve you're gonna
have to you know tweak The Tweak the
roster here and there the roster never
comes back uh fully intact there's
always something that goes on in terms
of free agency in the draft in the off
season but the core of the football team
Dan is Young and talented so you know I
I do think the core is going to remain
intact and there was a report that
burrows gonna get a contract and it's
going to be 50 million dollars a year
yeah that would not surprise me at all I
mean this guy is uh this is a special
dude there's no doubt about it he was
under duress to put it politely the uh
the Kansas City Chiefs number one in the
AFC and quarterback sacks and number two
in the NFL they had 55 during the course
of the year and they they uh garnered
five in the AFC Championship game and
man I'll tell you Chris Jones Frank
Clark full grown men didn't have any
didn't have many answers for those guys
I'll tell you they were they were
getting it done at the line of scrimmage
and you know everybody talks about three
rookies in the secondary they played
well but the old Axiom I believe uh in
very much your best pass defense is a
hellacious pass rush and they had one
yesterday
well congrats on the season and uh we'll
talk to you next year thank you Dave
thank you Dan I really appreciate it uh
you're you're an icon you're a legend
always love uh visiting you my man thank
you buddy that's uh Dave Lapham former
Bengals offensive lineman and uh been
doing the color commentating for Bengals
radio for over 30 years